fema says it is stepping up efforts to  help families of coronavirus victims pay  for their funerals  a program through the federal government  has paid out 85 million dollars to cover  expenses  but many families say the program's out  of reach frequently  death certificates don't mention covet  19.  fema administrators say the process is  intentionally difficult to protect  against fraud  but for families that lost loved ones to  the pandemic it is frustrating  it was kovac 19 but it wasn't on the  death certificate what happened there  honestly i didn't know what happened  because they asked they when the funeral  home asked us you know  what he died from they verified it  everything was you know covered 19  but it wasn't placed on the death  certificate  fema says it is now working with  families who may have been missed in  this program  next on 8 news now sounding the alarm on